did you have an official first date or
did you and what was that yeah so we had
a first date
um I was joking I was like listen listen
you need to um come because I played bad
that day or whatever it wasn't like my
best match and I was just saying it as
an aside like yeah you have to come you
know to Paris to see me play for real
and it wasn't like I had I literally did
not want him to come I like was not
thinking about it that way or anything
and then he's like oh yeah I'll be there
and I was like oh man what have I gotten
watch something too but it was good so
we went out our first we met in Rome our
first date was in Paris
yeah I'm a hopeless romantic too